we're gonna do an all green spring slaw
you actually want to take your cabbage
and then we want to slice it thinly I
mean I like it slice and add a little
sea salt once you add the salt and let
it press for about an hour and then
that's just kind of like bring all the
liquid out once you do that you just
want to rinse it and then you can you
know add it to the dish we have this
silken tofu as a base you can get silken
tofu pretty much any health food store
will add two tablespoons of this apple
cider vinegar we will squeeze one
tablespoon of this fresh lemon juice to
it we're gonna add this Dijon mustard so
I'm just gonna start pouring in the
olive oil as you're whisking it yeah you
can continue whisking as you're mixing
that I'm just gonna be adding all the
ingredients we need that garlic in there
to give it that pop of flavor that
because this be considered like an afro
vegan dish this was kind of squarely
inspired by growing up in the south but
living in Northern California we're in
like the hub of the kind of like good
food movement I think we should have a
little taste you mr. great mr. Bert Bert
so to fight the crunch
I like the garlic like the peas in the -
yeah yeah